the same thing is coming for all of us
[Music]
there is only one war with a positive
the Great Wall
and it is here
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight and Game Theory's video today I
will be answering some of the questions
you left me on my community tab I
noticed there was one particular
question I kept getting over and over
again this question also had the most
amount of likes I figured I should
address this one right away so without
further ado let's begin several
different people basically asked me the
same question so I will just read what
the top one says do you think that the
wave is posing as Arya we didn't exactly
see who won their final showdown what
could be the faceless men's motivation
for doing so the wife knows arias
background information what do you think
I think this theory is wrong for many
different reasons and just off the top
of my head there are at least four
different things that tell me this is
not true the first reason is because we
see the waist face hanging up in the
house a black and white
after Arya kills the wage she literally
removes her face and she places it on
the wall for Jack and a guard to see she
was pissed off because he sent the wife
to kill her but Arya wanted to prove she
is not so easily killed if the wife did
do this then that means she would have
cut her own face off because it's
clearly covered in blood the second
reason is because after Arya leaves
Braavos she immediately goes to the
twins and wipes out House Frey she kills
two of water sons then feeds them to him
after she watches him take a bite she
reveals who she really is
then slices his throat once Walder Frey
is dead Arya uses his face to kill the
rest of the men and his family if the
wife was actually wearing arias face why
would she go through all of this trouble
the wife would have no motivation to do
this Arya killed the phrase to avenge
her family the third reason is because
of what happened shortly after this as
Arya is heading to King's Landing to
kill Cersei she stops at the crossroads
in to get some grub when she is there
she reunites with hot pie who she
recognizes immediately do you mean to
tell me the wife would have known his
name was Hawkeye I mean come on but
anyways this is when she learns her
family has retaken Winterfell from the
Bolton's so she decides to go home
instead of going to King's Landing
she is heading north a pack of wolves
circle her and they are ready to rip her
throat out
but that's only until the leader of
their pack comes out and not only
recognizes it's Aria but also smells and
senses that it's Aria I know some people
still question whether this was supposed
to be named area or not but if you watch
the post-show after this episode the
producers confirm it is now area
obviously if this was the waif posing as
aria she would have been torn to pieces
by these wolves even Oreo was in danger
until Nami and calmed things down the
Starks and their dire wolves have a very
deep connection
Nymeria didn't just recognize arias face
she didn't even need to see arias face
to know that it was her Aria could have
had her back turned and she still would
have known these dire wolves were a gift
from the old gods they did not stumble
across these by accident they were sent
to them for a very specific reason
mostly to protect them but they have
also helped guide them and help them
make certain discoveries ghost leads
John to the white that is about to kill
Lord Commander Mormont John would not
have known if it wasn't for ghosts
getting his attention summer saves Bryan
when the assassin came to kill him
summer also leads Bryan to the weirwood
tree beyond the wall which is when
branches the tree for the first time and
has several different visions also in
the books ghost is actually the one who
discovers the Buried dragonglass near
the fist of the first men
they had Sam and Grenn find it in the
show but it's actually ghost who leads
Jon to the buried treasure the
direwolves play a very important role in
the story there are several great quotes
in the books that tell us exactly where
these dire wolves came from in a clash
of kings during one of Caitlyn's
chapters she says
the great John's been heard to say that
the old gods of the north sent those
dire wolves to your children Catelyn
remembered the day her boys had found
the pups in the late summer snows there
had been five three male and two female
for the five true born children of House
Stark and a sixth white of fur and red
of eye for Ned's bastard son Jon Snow no
common wolves she thought
no indeed in a Storm of Swords during
one of John's chapters he says red eyes
John realized but not like Melisandre he
had a weirwood sized red eyes red mouth
white fur blood and bone like a heart
tree he belongs to the old guns this one
and another one of Caitlin's chapters
and this is what was said any man gray
when Miss likes is a man I do not want
close to you these wolves are more than
wolves Robb you must know that I think
perhaps the God sent them to us
your father's gods the old gods of the
north five wolf pups Rob five four five
stark children six said Rob there was a
wolf for John as well I found them
remember I know how many there were and
where they came from I used to think the
same as you that these wolves were our
Guardians our protectors there are many
more examples than this but as you can
see these dire wolves were a gift to the
Stars they were sent to watch over them
and protect them their bond is much
deeper than just facial recognition so
do you really think if the wife murdered
Arya and was wearing her face that
Nymeria would just allow her to continue
to do this there is no way in hell
Nymeria would have let the wife out of
her sight while wearing arias face she
would have known and she would have
killed her the last reason has to do
with Orias brother bran bran is now the
three-eyed Raven Bryan has basically
seen everything they have been through
he saw sons they get married in the
godswood which took place in season five
he also saw Arya contemplating whether
or not to go and kill sir see if Arya
was actually dead bran would know bran
is now the last green seer and he can
see far beyond the weirwood trees now in
a dance with dragons this is what brain
was told a weirwood will live forever if
undisturbed
to them seasons pass in a flutter of a
moss swing and past present and future
are one nor will your sight be limited
to your gods would the singers carve
dyes into their heart trees to awaken
them
and those are the first eyes a new green
seer learns to use but in time you will
see well beyond the trees themselves
brain is now a very powerful green seer
nefaria died I believe he would no he
would not have handed the wife that
valerian still dagger he would have
warned everyone at Winterfell that an
impostor was heading their way but these
are just my opinions I know this theory
would make things a little more
interesting to some people but I just
don't believe it to be true all right
now let's move on to the next question
and this one comes from my friend Mel of
Winterfell she says do you think more
people knew of John's lineage did aim on
benzene or even Littlefinger no it's
hard to believe more people didn't know
about Leona and Rhaegar especially since
they were together so long before lianna
died this is a good question because
I've wondered this myself and I came to
the conclusion that maester aemon might
have known I actually made a video about
this that video is called the three-eyed
raven secret alliance I highly recommend
that you watch that video because I went
in depth about how I think this is
possible and what take me too long to
explain everything again
but basically what I think is maester
aemon and the three-eyed raven may have
still been in communication with each
other after all these years for those of
you that don't know the three-eyed Raven
was actually in the Nights Watch many
years ago he joined the Nights Watch at
the same exact time as maester aemon
they even traveled to the wall together
not only did they serve at the wall
together but they are related both of
them are Targaryen just like John
Rhaegar Targaryen Aemon Targaryen Jon
Snow and the three-eyed Raven also known
as Brendan rivers are all related by
blood
when maester aemon and the three-eyed
Raven arrived at the wall together Amon
obviously became the maester and Brendan
soon became the Lord Commander this
means maester aemon would have spent a
lot of time with them while they served
together they served at the wall
together for over thirteen years so you
can only imagine how many conversations
they may have had and Brendan was
already dabbling into the dark arts and
prophecy he was already known for having
a connection with the Ravens especially
since he was the master of whisperers
when he was in King's Landing and can
you guess who took
the Ravens at the wall Maester Aemon was
in charge of the Rookery and we know
this is the three-eyed Ravens main
source of communication there is a ton
of evidence in the books that hint at
the three-eyed raven controlling the
birds at the wall he doesn't just
control them but he actually makes them
speak when Lord Commander Mormont tells
John about maester aemon's family
he tells John how Jaime Lannister killed
the last dragon king the Mad King
but the raven looks directly at John and
calls him a king and the Raven never
takes his eyes off of John the raven who
is being controlled by the three-eyed
raven is telling us all the dragon Kings
are not dead because john is obviously a
secret Targaryen king now I don't know
if maester aemon knew everything Brendan
was up to but I think they may have to
continue talking even after he went
missing beyond the wall and ultimately
became the three-eyed Raven I think he
may have told maester aemon about John
he could have told him that one day John
would join him at the wall and he would
need to watch over him and give him
guidance or counsel to keep him on track
the three-eyed raven could have even
been sending maester aemon dreams about
john and i think this is why maester
aemon was immediately drawn to john when
he came to the wall I think he knew John
had Targaryen blood just go back and
listen to all the things maester aemon
would say to John to me it really seemed
like he knew more than he was willing to
admit when maester aemon gives John that
kill the boys speech he does it a little
differently in the books before he gives
John that advice he reaches out and he
touches John's face when he does this it
immediately makes maester aemon think of
Aegon Targaryen he says he gave Aegon
the same speech before he left for the
wall so there's an obvious connection
here as we all know John is actually
named Aegon Targaryen as well and Eamon
gives the same speech to two different
Aegon's if any other people knew the
truth about John I would bet on maester
aemon knowing after you finish watching
this go check out my video called the
three-eyed raven secret alliance in that
video I back up this theory with several
quotes and examples of the three-eyed
raven keeping an eye on things at the
wall and
bet a ma knew what was on I will
actually pin the link to the video at
the top of the comment section that way
it's easier to find all right now let's
move on to the next question and this
next question comes from Victor Vaughn
Deathstroke do you think Jamie has to
die to complete his character arc this
is a really good question because I
think Jamie is one of the most
complicated characters in the story and
I also think he's one of the most
interesting characters in the story
I don't know if he necessarily has to
die to complete his story arc or
redemption arc but I do believe he will
die in the end I think Jamie is linked
to brain stark
through his heinous act of throwing him
out the window so I suspect they will
meet again next season I think Jamie may
a brain in the fight against the others
then he may die there with his honor
regained or he may end up doing
something after that which could be tied
in with killing Cersei and stopping her
from blowing up King's Landing the show
could also have Jamie die with Cersei or
in the arms of the woman that he loves
which is now Brienne in my opinion but
whatever it is it must have a huge
impact on the story since this show has
been slowly developing Jamie the last
few seasons I'm hoping they make up for
lost time in the next couple episodes I
think Jamie still has a massive role to
play he could save one of the Starks
lives in the Great War then he could
even save King's Landing from Total
Annihilation again Jamie's empty pages
in the white book has haunted him for a
very long time he does not want to die
with only being known as the man who
killed the king he had sworn to protect
now that Jaime will no longer be
influenced by Circe's madness I think he
will do whatever it takes to be seen as
an honorable man now maybe this is just
what SFIL thinking on my part but I know
Jamie wants to do the right thing and
now he no longer has anything holding
him back so do I think he needs to die
to complete his character arc this all
depends on how big he steps up he might
not have to but I don't see him making
it out of both wars alive I just had
this feeling Jaime will give his life to
save some others but maybe I'm wrong
what do all of you think about Jamie's
Redemption arc do you believe he has to
die in order to complete it I will have
to cut this video a little short today
but I have all the other questions saved
so I will make another one
these videos sometime next week I also
have more foreshadowing videos to do and
more chapter readings to do I have a
bunch of other videos coming up this
week so keep your notifications on that
way you can be alerted as soon as they
get uploaded I want to thank you all for
stopping by to watch the video and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for continuing to support the channel I
really appreciate that I hope you all
have a great day I will see you again
very soon
bye
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]